Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Have you heard the saying that whenever we
look into the mirror, strictly speaking, we
don’t really see ourselves, but we see ourselves
from the past…from a few nanoseconds ago.
Is that true?
If so, why?
This is indeed true, and the reason for this
is that the speed of light is finite, and
it has to travel back from the mirror to our
eyes.
If you feel that this is really hard to imagine,
you are in luck, because a legendary paper
from 2013 by the name Femto-photography captured
this effect.
I would say it is safe to start holding on
to your papers from this point basically until
the end of this video.
Here you can see a super high-speed camera
capturing how a wave of light propagates through
a bottle, most makes it through, and some
gets absorbed by the bottle cap.
But this means that this mirror example we
talked about shall not only be a thought experiment,
but we can even witness it ourselves.
Yup, toy first, mirror image second.
Approximately a nanosecond apart.
So if someone says that you look old, you
have an excellent excuse now.
The first author of this work was Andreas
Velten, who worked on this at MIT, and he
is now a professor leading an incredible research
group at the University of Wisconsin, Madison.
But wait…since it is possible to create
light transport simulations, in which we simulate
the path of many-many millions of light rays
to create a beautiful, photorealistic image,
Adrián Jarabo thought that he would create
a simulator that wouldn’t just give us the
final image, but he would show us the propagation
of light in a digital, simulated environment.
As you see here, with this, we can create
even crazier experiments because we are not
limited to the real-world light conditions
and the limitations of the camera.
The beauty of this technique is just unparalleled.
He calls this method transient rendering,
and this particular work is tailored to excel
at rendering caustic patterns.
A caustic is a beautiful phenomenon in nature
where curved surfaces reflect or refract light,
thereby concentrating it to a relatively small
area.
I hope that you are not surprised when I say
that it is the favorite phenomenon of most
light transport researchers.
Now, a word about these caustics.
We need a super efficient technique to be
able to pull this off.
For instance, back in 2013, we showcased a
fantastic scene made by Vlad Miller that was
a nightmare to compute, and it took a community
effort and more than a month to accomplish
it.
Beyond that, the transient renderer only uses
very little memory, builds on the photon beams
technique we talked about a few videos ago,
and always arrives to a correct solution,
given enough time.
Bravo!
And we can do all this, through the power
of science.
Isn’t it incredible?
And if you feel a little stranded at home
and are yearning to learn more about light
transport, I held a Master-level course on
light transport simulations at the Technical
University of Vienna.
Since I was always teaching it to a handful
of motivated students, I thought that the
teachings shouldn’t only be available for
the privileged few who can afford a college
education, but the teachings should be available
for everyone.
So, the course is now available free of charge
for everyone, no strings attached, so make
sure to click the link in the video description
to get started.
We write a full light simulation program from
scratch there, and learn about physics, the
world around us, and more.
This episode has been supported by Weights
& Biases.
In this post, they show you how to build and
track a simple neural network in Keras to
recognize characters from the Simpsons series.
You can even fork this piece of code and start
right away.
Weights & Biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning projects.
Their system is designed to save you a ton
of time and money, and it is actively used
in projects at prestigious labs, such as OpenAI,
Toyota Research, GitHub, and more.
And, the best part is that if you are an academic
or have an open source project, you can use
their tools for free.
It really is as good as it gets.
Make sure to visit them through wandb.com/papers
or just click the link in the video description
and you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to Weights & Biases for their long-standing
support and for helping us make better videos
for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!